hey guys it's December 21st I'm chastity
a few games are getting into the
Christmas spirit this week by rolling
out holiday events here's a couple more
[Music]
first up Final Fantasy 15 s Christmas
content and new game plus mode Final
Fantasy 15 s latest patches out now
bringing a new game plus mode as its
standout feature this updates new game
plus mode allows you to play through the
main story over again once you complete
it you can carry over all your existing
weapons magic and skills into your
second run according to neogaf user
Raymond 1990 the mode apparently does
not offer any new difficulty options
meanwhile your ultimate blade and
regalia will return to their base states
the update also includes
christmas-themed photo frames for your
prompt Oh selfies a full holiday DLC
pack drops on december twenty second
next up battlefield ones holiday event
begins today battlefield one special
event begins today and runs until
December 29th with new things to do on
unlock every day today battlefield one
adds a new custom game called blind
delivery this is a variant of the war
pigeons mode where the mini-map is
turned off also weaponry is limited to
hand guns and explosives you can find
blind delivery in the custom game tab of
battlefield ones multiplayer menu on
December 22nd a dog tag called holiday
truce will be available all you have to
do to get it is log in to the game
anytime that day later in the week EA
will offer new vehicle skins and battle
packs you can see a full rundown of
events on gamespot com and heads up you
can play star wars battlefront step star
DLC for free this weekend there are a
few good reasons to play star wars
battlefront this weekend EA has
announced that the game's Death Star DLC
will be free for everyone December 23rd
to 25th while the game will also pay out
double xp during that time not only that
but everyone gets 5,000 credits just for
logging in EA says it's offering the
promotion to celebrate the holidays the
Death Star DLC which originally came out
in September includes new map set on the
Death Star as well as a multi-stage
battle station mode this essentially
lets you recreate Luke Skywalker's
trench run from a new hope culminating
in the destruction of the giant weapon
all of the Death Star's maps and modes
are available during the free play
weekend though it's not immediately
clear if the dlcs heroes weapons and
star cards are available as well let me
know what you think of today's stories
in the comments below and head over to
gamespot com to see what we thought of
the assassins creed movie and for more
movie content head over to gamespot
universe and don't forget to subscribe
it's our permanent home for movies TV
and comics as a January third subscribe
now so you never miss a video I'm
chastity and I'll see you tomorrow